let's look at this a lot of people had a
go at GV news I Was Myself speaking to
newscast where they went on and on and
on and on about due in partiality which
I actually felt I had to explain yeah
but did you notice in a lot of the stuff
there literally wasn't any at all no
there wasn't any at all it was very
interesting watching the BBC have a
debate on news night with three of the
the three people taking part and the
chair were all pro taking GB news off it
and let's actually look at what they why
they want GB news taken off there
because Lawrence Fox May this stays full
and somewhat people some people would
argue misogynistic comments yet that
comes barely a week and a half after the
Russell Brand allegations which were
incredibly serious when one of them was
that they used BBC cars to go and pick
up a 16 year old girl from her school
and then transport her to Russell's flat
allegations may I add that to me is far
more serious if you look at all the BBC
News presenters that have been involved
or allegedly involved in horrific
Behavior including crimes like
pedophilia no one ever mentioned that we
should shut down the BBC no one ever
mentioned hey look we should defund them
they were criticized and rightly so yet
somebody comes on and says nasty words
about a fellow journalist and we're
going to defund and take the entire
Channel off here to me that is a sign
that there's something else going on it
does seem a bit odd and I mean I'd like
to say that you know obviously the BBC
aren't here to defend himself but some
of the things that you said I mean
unfortunately those things happened so
yes about it and you had the situation
with Bashir as well where there was some
sort of forgery going on with the
statements to Princess Diana and that
may well have contributed to her
agreeing to do that interview we found
out that there was some sort of cover-up
around that so it does seem a little bit
Rich for these people all to descend
even ITV descending on us I mean did you
see on the way they descended on
Michelle dubry no I didn't see the
weather but but look none of this
surprises me Nana because what you get
in the mainstream media is you get one
opinion that is all you get now I made
very slightly to the left or slightly to
the right and occasionally you know
they'll uh wheeled null due they'll will
Nigel farage out and they'll treat him
like Jimmy Savile you know they are
accused of all these horrendous crimes
you know he what his Pro brexit and his
right wing and they'll say he's a racist
and a fascist slightly to the right of
Hitler and then that'll be it but the
reality is you are going to get one
opinion on the mainstream well that's it
whereas what you get here yeah and this
is something that is never spoken about
and it's very important and I just want
to make clear that I I come on and do GP
news once a week I am not a regular
commentator but you get Aaron bastani
who is so left wing Bliss Aaron I love
him but he's so far to the left he's
almost over the horizon you'll get
people to the right you'll get people in
the center you'll get people you know
little bit naughty maybe so and I think
that is brilliant that is what you want
from a broadcaster to platform a range
of views and you are not going to get
that in the BBC and if they do bring
someone on it's because they want to
tear them down mock them make them look
stupid but here's the thing the reason
they're doing it is because they're
terrified because they are hemorrhaging
viewers and listeners day after day
after day